Hi there, Amy.
How are you today?
Good.
Okay, so I am just gonna
give you a quick breast exam.
Go ahead and lay back
and relax.
Okay.
So, have you had any new
sexual partners
since the last time I saw you?
Oh, nnn...
What do you
consider sex?
Penetration or...?
Well, no, there's all kinds
of different kinds of sex.
Okay, then, yes, a bunch,
but we used a condom.
Their call.
Okay, great.
So I'm gonna have you
put your feet in the stirrups
and I want you to slide all the
way to the end of the table
so that I can take a look
at your pussy.
All the way down.
Like, slide your pussy
all the way down
to the end of the table.
Okay.
When was the last time you were
bleeding out of your pussy?
Um, two weeks ago.
Can-- Can you not
refer to it as that?
Oh, I'm sorry.
When were you menstruating
out your pussy?
No, the um...
The-- Can you not say...
"pussy"?
Oh, yeah, sure, fine.
Whatever.
Okay, so I'm gonna take
two fingers,
I'm gonna put 'em
in your hair pie.
I'm gonna feel around, apply
some pressure to your ovaries
and check you out
for beav cancer, okay?
Listen...
Oh, did I press too hard?
I apologize.
No.
Okay, well,
everything feels fine,
so now I'm just gonna go ahead
and clamp your clam open
and then swab around
the inside of your tuna taco
and I'll have you
on your way.
Yeah, no.
Can you just use
the clinical term for vagina?
I don't-- I don't see what's so
hard about just saying vagina.
I don't understand.
Are you referring to your
sausage wallet?
Sausage wallet?
You know, your lizard mouth.
Does it really feel normal
to you to refer to it this way?
I-- That would be like a
proctologist calling a butt a--
(gagging)
Butt?
(wretching)
Oh, God.
I'm sorry.
I think I got some in your
steaming hot pocket.
00:02:19,431 --> 00:00:00,000
I'll get--
let me clean that up.